researchers say heat related deaths in
the Middle East and North Africa will be
60 times Higher by the end of the
century if no climate action is taken
the London School of hygiene and
tropical medicine medicine predicts that
in a worst case scenario about 123
people in every 100 000 will die and
that's far more than any other region in
the world let's get more should we uh
here to give us her thoughts is
Professor Elizabeth Robinson who is the
director of the Grantham Research
Institute at the London School of
Economics high it's good to see you
thank you very much indeed how worried
are you
uh pretty concerned actually I think
this new report looking to Middle East
and North Africa in particular is just
showing how vulnerable we are to the
impacts of climate change and I think
it's becoming clear and clearer that
climate change is one of the greatest
threats to human health and the impact
of heat on our health is one particular
example of that but there's many others
okay where will people suffer most
well uh it certainly places are already
hot and that are going to get hotter so
this this recent report looks at Middle
East and North Africa and so what
they're projecting is um in the worst
case scenarios we're going to see during
summer about half of summer days are
going to be Heat Wave days and So within
those regions we're going to be
particularly concerned about much older
people younger people and people with
pre-existing conditions but here in the
in Europe we've seen a lot of deaths
from heat already so in the 2003 heat
waves we saw about 15 000 deaths from
heat alone in France
adaptation Works adaptation is really
important so by 2019 there were just
1500 deaths in France from a worse Heat
Wave but but then the UK would be
worried
because we've already seen deaths from
from heat here so we need to be around
for several reasons one the impact here
in the UK and so we need to work hard on
adaptation reducing mitigation but also
we're very interconnected worlds so that
impacts that happen in one part of the
world are likely to affect us and that's
in part through populations overseas we
could think even of food security a lot
of our food comes from overseas and
that's going to be harmed by global
warming oh my goodness me
um how preventable is it
it is preventable uh you you showed the
um the data there that suggests we're
already about 1.1 degrees or more above
pre-industrial levels which doesn't
sound a lot but already we're starting
to see those impacts so we're likely to
see between 1.5 and 2 degrees of warming
but we can reduce warming through
um rapidly reducing our emissions and
part of that is a rapid transition to
renewable energy part of that is
changing the way we eat and travel and
so there are solutions but we have to
act fast in the next sort of seven eight
years we want to see global emissions
halving and so that's going to be hard
but doable how hot is it going to get I
remember being in Australia in the 1980s
and being in an area in central
Australia where I did a piece of camera
and say and it gets up to 42 degrees
here oh my goodness it was that it was
40 degrees in the UK last year it was
and I think quite a lot of us were quite
surprised that we were already in 2022
getting temperatures of up to 40 in the
UK and what we hear in the Middle East
and North Africa is temperatures up to
50 are going to be normalized by the end
of the century and we have human beings
cope with that so uh yes and no so in
part it depends on adaptation but what
we do know is above 35 degrees
Centigrade with sufficient humidities
our bodies simply can't cope and so uh
when it's that hot and that humid We
Can't Sweat and so we can't keep our
core temperature regulated
and even even coming up to those
temperatures we're putting tremendous
pressure on our cardiovascular systems
because our hearts have to pump harder
to take the blood around our body to
cool us down and so if you're older if
you have a pre-existing heart condition
you're far more vulnerable to the
impacts of heat almost out of time top
tips for staying dealing with this uh
individually if you're older access to
cooling early warning systems are really
important make sure you have access to
cooling for example
um governments can help by ensuring
there's air conditioning Cooling in um
in hospitals in Care Homes but really um
access to cooling is important drinking
lots of water so rehydration is really
important okay it's fascinating stuff
thank you very much thank you thank you